the russian ukraine conflict has
obviously got the eyes of the world and
of course as soon as you see financial
sanctions and all types of censorship
people immediately jump and start
talking about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies as a tool for russia to
evade those sanctions there's a lot of
people who are presenting these
technologies as simply being able to
help the bad guys but that's not
actually the only way remember bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies these are
neutral technologies they can be used by
friend or foe and what we saw over the
weekend was that the official ukraine
government came out and they actually
solicited donations from the global
population saying stand with the people
of ukraine they now are accepting
cryptocurrency donations bitcoin
ethereum and usdt they included the
addresses for those types of assets that
anyone in the world with an internet
connection that had bitcoin ethereum or
tether could simply go ahead and donate
to the ukraine cause now what we saw is
that actually on a public ledger you can
see exactly who's donating how much and
where those assets are going and so
elliptic put together this graphic that
shows that about 56
came in bitcoin 31 in ethereum and about
10 or so coming in stable coins and
ultimately those crypto assets were
being donated they're there to help the
ukraine people go ahead and buy critical
supplies in their defense of their
sovereign nation now i don't think very
many people had on their 2022 bingo cart
that we would see a nation state openly
soliciting donations from the global
population in bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies but when you have all
sorts of economic sanctions when you
have inferior technology around two or
three days settlement times in the u.s
dollar system or the legacy banking
system it is becoming very obvious that
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies are
superior technology anyone with an
internet connection can go ahead and now
send economic value to the cause that
they want to support and ultimately
ukraine is pioneering a positive use for
these technologies plenty of people
continue to talk about the negative uses
of bitcoin and cryptocurrencies in times
of violent conflict but ukraine putting
on an example of exactly why these
technologies can help the good people as
well